So before we were dragging fields onto the page.
>> Uh-huh.
>> But now what were trying to drag on, is a list of related records.
>> Okay, so I should click Related List over here.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay, good. Set times, and I'll drag it down and that's lovely.
>> Awesome. Click Save. Don't forget that guy.
>> Thank you. You've added or moved Related Lists
to this page layout. Yeah, I always want to overwrite.
>> We want everyone to see the set times.
>> Yeah. Set times are important.
Cool, set times. But that's totally lame, I don't care about ST 0001.
>> Yeah.
>> Can I get more information than it?
>> So the auto-number isn't too useful. But we
can also from the page layout modify what shows up
in this related list. So let's actually go back
into the layout, or page layout editor and fix that.